also ich bin da Auffassung ist genügt
nicht dass einige Politiker zurückrudern
oder sich nur einfach in irgendeiner Art
und Weise für einige Teile der
corona-politik z.B Kita Schließung oder
Schulschließungen entschuldigen ich
halte es finden wesentlich und wichtig
dass es eine politische eine mediale und
auch eine juristische Aufarbeitung gibt
um auch die Gesellschaft und deren
Spaltung und diese ganzen
Diskriminierung die stattgefunden haben
auch zu Hannes braucht eine
gesellschaftliche und politische und
juristische Gerechtigkeit das ist der
eine Punkt in Florida z.B wird jetzt die
Pharmaindustrie in dem Fall soweit ich
weiß Pfizer und moderner verklagt in
Washington hat man jetzt einen
Untersuchungsausschuss eingeleitet um
die Dinge aufzuarbeiten weil man eben
auch die Verknüpfung zwischen
politischen Interessen und
Konzerninteressen aufarbeiten möchte und
ich halte das für wesentlich es auch
hier in Deutschland zu tun es gibt zum
Beispiel solche Themen also natürlich
spricht man jetzt zum Beispiel über die
die schweren Folgen für Kinder aber es
gibt zum Beispiel auch die Situation in
Seniorenheimen in Kliniken denen man
besuchsverbote erteilt hat obwohl das
nach Paragraph 28a absatz 2 Satz 2
Infektionsschutzgesetz sogar im Gesetz
stehend formell gesetzlich verboten war
es gibt die mittelbare Impfpflicht die
durch 2G entstanden ist die jetzt zum
Beispiel Lichtenstein als
verfassungswidrig erklärt wurde es gibt
die versammlungsverbote die man gemacht
hat und und zwar im kleineren und großen
Maße sei es Demonstrationen sei es
Konzerte die man zum Beispiel im
Straßburger Menschen Gerichtshof als
menschenrechtswidrig erklärt hat es gab
Kultur lockdowns die wir abgekriegt
haben als Künstler die jetzt zum
Beispiel im österreichischen
Verfassungsgericht zumindest beim
dritten Lockdown als verfassungswidrig
erklärt wurden und es gibt natürlich
auch so Dinge wie die fehlende
Aufklärung das ist zum Beispiel eine
bedingte Zulassung ist dass man
bestimmte Nebenwirkungen noch gar nicht
einschätzen kann das ist ein
gentechnisches Therapeutikum ist und das
ist eine bedingte Zulassung ist die so
niemals kommuniziert wurden jedenfalls
nicht in der Form das ist die
Allgemeinheit wenn man jetzt kein ist
oder Journalist wie sie in der Form
hätte verstehen können und ich finde es
ist extrem wichtig dass wir im Bundestag
einen unabhängigen neutralen
Untersuchungsausschuss haben und die
Politik der zwei Legislaturperioden die
damit einhergeht aufarbeiten und
eventuell auch Konsequenzen gezogen
werden
da müssen Rücktritte beispielsweise
kommen das halte ich eigentlich für
normal also ich komme ich bin schon
etwas länger auf der Welt und früher
haben ganz andere Dinge gereicht um
Rücktritte zu erzeugen ich kenne jetzt
zwölf Selbstmorde aus meiner Branche die
einfach mal kurz passiert sind weil man
gesagt hat alle müssen jetzt sofort
irgendwie nicht mehr arbeiten dürfen
nicht mehr arbeiten
Tätigkeitsverbot für uns was
Berufsverbot ja aber zum Beispiel
mehreren Bundesländern gab es 9 Monate
gar kein Geld oder 7 Monate wie jetzt
z.B in Rheinland-Pfalz ja da sind dann
Existenzen ruiniert worden und wir haben
jetzt natürlich z.B in Club sterben
Kultur sterben wir haben eine
Gesellschaft wie gewohnt ist auf dem
Sofa zu sitzen und Netflix zuschauen
dass sich die Konzertsäle nicht füllen
dass ich die Branche gar nicht richtig
wieder auf die Beine kommt naja es ist
halt es ist halt so dass es publiziert
wurde also Kultur ist nicht
systemrelevant ist sie nicht nach dem
Sozialpakt an fünf ist die kulturelle
Teilhabe extrem wichtig auch für die
Gesellschaft also Daseins Fürsorge die
gehört zum Menschenrecht dazu und wenn
man den Menschen gegenüber suggeriert
ihr könnt euch die kulturelle Teilhabe
irgendwie beim Fernsehen oder im
Streaming abholen und man braucht gar
nicht mehr zum Konzert zu gehen ist ein
völlig anderes Erlebnis dann spürt man
das schon also wir haben jetzt z.B
Patricia Kelly hat eine Tour absagen
müssen weil sie gesagt hat und die Frau
ist sehr erfolgreich
sie kann es nicht stimmen sie kann die
Tournee nicht ständig Leute haben
entweder noch nicht geschafft sich
wieder daran zu gewöhnen in die Menge zu
gehen oder sie sind immer noch daran
gewöhnt mehr zu Hause zu bleiben und wie
gesagt bleibt zu Hause seid ihr Helden
das muss man den Menschen eigentlich
wieder klar machen es ist vorbei
kommt wieder in die Konzerte kultur ist
ein wesentlicher Faktor für eine
Demokratie und vor allen Dingen für ein
gesundes gesellschaftliches Gesamtbild
haben Sie das Gefühl dass die gesamte
Gesellschaft noch sehr darunter leidet
noch sehr unter der Pandemie und ihren
Folgen leider absolut das sieht man ich
bin britischer Staatsbürger auch also
ich habe gesehen am 19.07 21 war in UK
alles vorbei da ging das Leben normal
weiter wo wir hier noch teilweise im
Lockdown saßen und ähm die sind da ganz
anders mit umgegangen auch in Holland
wir haben bei uns auf dem Hof wo ich
herkomme noch ein kleines Hotel und die
Gäste die aus dem Ausland zu uns kamen
die haben uns immer angeguckt mit großen
Augen was macht ihr hier und das war so
also das was gesagt hat wir müssen aus
diesem zugegebenen Fehlern die wir jetzt
dazu geben dringend lernen wenn ich aber
Frau Faser höre ich war mal bis 2010
hier bei der Polizei in Berlin tätig
wenn ich dann höre wir können unser
demokratisches Recht auf Versammlung von
zu Hause wahrnehmen dann spricht das
Ende ganz ehrlich also wir müssen
irgendwann auch zur Normalität
zurückkommen wir müssen uns auch offen
und hier auch mal ein bisschen Klartext
reden das geht und uns danach in die
Augen gucken können und sagen ist in
Ordnung das müssen wir wieder lernen
streiten gesund streiten wo wir eingangs
darüber gesprochen haben sonst sonst
wird die Gesellschaft gar nicht heilen
ist ein Entschuldigung ein zurückrudern
ein Fehler einsehen einfach nicht genug
braucht es da mehr Aufarbeitung seitens
der Politik geht die nicht weit genug in
deinen Augen also wir müssen ein paar
Sachen auseinander Polen da sind jetzt
ganz viele Katzen in einem Sack drin die
müssen noch mal nacheinander rausnehmen
also die ganz viele Entscheidungen haben
sich als dann im Nachhinein als falsch
herausgestellt da gehört es zum guten
Ton dass man sich dafür entschuldigt
oder dass man es zumindest sagt dass man
Fehler
von diesen Entscheidungen sind ganz
viele nicht bewusst gegen Leute gemacht
worden sondern es gab einen anderen
Impetus das war in der ersten Phase wo
man nicht wusste was tatsächlich los und
nicht jedes nur von der ersten Phase ich
rede nicht von dem ganzen Jahr da war
ganz viel aus Unwissenheit quasi da ist
man in eine Höhle gegangen hat sich
zurückgezogen draußen ein unbekanntes
Raubtier war man hat dann den Schritt
verpasst wieder rauszugehen man ist
ängstlich drin sitzen geblieben und da
muss man dann tatsächlich auch der
Politik einen wirklich konkreten Vorwurf
machen und die Kinder und die
kita-schließung damals die waren das hat
man zum Teil damals schon gewusst es gab
ja andere Experten die andere Sachen
gesagt haben als sie die damals
beteiligt waren es gab auch Politiker
die in einer anderen Meinung waren zum
Beispiel selbst Karl Lauterbach weil man
dagegen
das muss man schlicht und ergreifen
aufarbeiten da bin ich völlig bei auch
völlig bei Frauen bei Frau Neigel das
muss aufgearbeitet werden das gehört
auch zur politischen Hygiene mit dazu
dass man egal aus welchen Gründen man
Entscheidungen getroffen hat ich
unterstelle nicht aus Böswilligkeit aber
wenn sie sich im Nachhinein als falsch
herausstellen dann gehört es sich
schlicht untergreifend und auch um das
in Zukunft zu vermeiden dass man das
überprüft ich möchte nur eins richtig
stellen der biontech und der moderner
Impfstoff das sind keine gentechnischen
Therapeutikum nein sind es nicht du bist
zwischen Gesundheitsministerium
einer Woche jetzt nach dem
informationsfreiheitsgesetzen
es wird nur aus politischen Gründen nach
der EU als Impfung deklariert weil es
eben in diesem Fall um Corona geht und
Corona ist ein
Infektionskrankheiten
die wollen uns alle nur irgendwie
täuschen und es war und ich will auch
dem Eindruck entgegentreten dass da
Konzerne mit der Politik im Haushalt
hätten um Gewinne wegen da waren
tatsächlich Leute daran haben ganze ganz
Abteilungen Tag und Nacht gearbeitet
über Monate sind hinterher fast
zusammengebrochen ich unterstelle dann
niemanden von vornherein eigennutzt
alles mögliche das damit Geld verdient
worden ist ja das ist so das ist mit
anderen Sachen auch so aber bestimmt ihn
ja völlig zu dass man hinterher einfach
gucken muss was ist da was ist da
passiert was ist falsch gelaufen und
dann muss es auch Konsequenzen geben und
das geht nicht dass ich Helge braun
einfach verabschiedet der Mann war
damals viel Immunität sterile Immunität
und das wissen wir und ich wollte ihnen
noch mal zu dieser gentherapeutischen
Sache interessant
CEO von Bayern von Bayern der hat 2001
ganz klar gesagt also hätten wir Corona
nicht gehabt würde die Zell und
Gentherapie kann man im Video nachsehen
entschuldigen
uns darauf einigen das ist kein
technisch veränderter Impfstoff ist das
ist nicht kein Ende kann ich jetzt nicht
beurteilen ich bin kein Mediziner aber
es ist ein gentechnisches Therapeutikum
und dazu gibt es mehrere Studien und das
sagen ganz viele Ärzte und
Wissenschaftler
mir geht's nur darum dass der Eindruck
nicht erweckt wird dass er gegen
technisch rum manipuliert worden darum
geht es mir nur gut
kann Ihnen nur sagen dann sind wir in
Bayern ob Vorsatz oder nicht ich bin
kein Richter ich bin kein Arzt ich bin
einfach ganz normale BürgerInnen und ich
habe mich viele informiert ich hatte
viel Zeit ich hatte Berufsverbot und
eins weiß ich zum Beispiel schon etwas
länger Pfizer hat einen Schadensbericht
im Februar 2021 an die CDC verschickt
und das waren ja auch die die dann
praktisch die Schadensberichte an die
immer schicken mussten nur der Vertrieb
und in diesem Schadensbericht das 21.2
aus 21 aus dem Februar steht auf Seite
17 Kubik 19 und schwere Verläufe ist
eine Nebenwirkung dieses Produktes und
danach kommt ab Seite 30 bis Seite 38
unglaublicher unglaubliche
Nebenwirkungen in also wirklich in dem
Hintergrund
so eine Liste
hat hat
wenn ich zum Arzt gehen mich impfen
lassen weil meine Frau hat in der Praxis
gearbeitet oder arbeitet in
der Praxis die auch inflammen natürlich
kriegst du als Patient dann nicht den
Beipackzettel zu deiner impfdings zu
deiner Fiola aber es gibt einen
Aufklärungsbogen es gibt Ärzte die
aufklären müssen so fast gar nichts drin
und die Beipackzettel wurden entfernt
über eine Verordnung die im Mai 2020 von
Herrn Spahn höchst persönlich
erforderlich
es gibt zu einer phiolin nicht sechs
beipassen
wie gesagt Aufklärung die Medis vs
glaube ich hieß die wurde 2020
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie